hi guys how have I not heard of this
game yet it's same saying it's fine is
just perfect for this channel or my
daughter understand right now this is
bendy and the Inca Shane if you haven't
heard of it yet it's basically won't
Disney but horror it's like a short
horror game Disney I don't know much
about it but from what it seems there's
a lot of story elements to do with it
quite like by myself ready and I know a
lot of you guys enjoyed my five nights
at Freddy's way through so without
further ado but play it again this is
chapter one chapter two is out as well
and chapter three is being made so we
should be able to get to play all these
I don't know how many they will be like
hi cooking I don't stop rambling play
the game okay dear moon it seems like a
lifetime since we've worked on cartoons
together thirty years really slips away
doesn't it if you're back in town come
visit the old workshop there's something
I need to show you your best pal
Joey Drew cool alright Joey I'm here
let's see if we can find what you wanted
me to see first of all could I apologize
if this game doesn't run at the best
framerate hopefully you'll do for this
one video if it's not going to work
since well we'll see if I have to endure
it then you're going to have to ensure
but hopefully it can still be fun anyway
I'm just moving in a Winnie weird
fashion
a really a really weird question okay so
I'm very tiny I'm only a little bit
taller than the chair but that's fine
I'm pretty sure I'm realizing anyways
okay so this is a little cartoon and it
says no nope not good enough
that's not good enough can i watch a
movie
oh okay
turned off the freaky but fine so from
what I know because I did see game
series video on this which is very
interesting and that's why I wanted to
play it mainly good for the theories and
stuff but it's kind of related to what
actually have a good Walt Disney like
the real history and today I think
they're gonna introduce some i/o and use
my old desk
my desk wasted so much time in this
chair that's where you work it's a
hallway though one you have your own
office or anything this is the hallway
okay Oh was it nice
did you always paint with this so we've
got founder Oh desk
what are we doing never
oh yeah kinda crazy Cherie that's not
cheat huh hey toilet [ __ ] yard
[Music]
so guessing is a doors aren't open
they're probably love dreams come true
hmm hey we got us up the weapon think
can I get it no maybe not hmm
[Music]
that was my brother's friend Kyle lie in
it tuck it in there music
so this is the Inka machine I wonder how
you turn it on gotta be a button here
somewhere ink maybe maybe there's
something in another room let's go look
I'm sorry anyone else here am I on my
own but this place has been abandoned
for a while dancing demons what a plank
of wood foul but there's no hole from
where I've found the ceiling just a
stray bit of wood oh my god
oh my god Joey what were you doing
are these like people in suits or is it
just like a life-sized what the hell is
this is that a Bible
the illusion of living hmm who's
laughing now
so I'm guessing are they all kind of
representative representatives of the
real Walt Disney cartoon characters so
he would be was that dogs that walks
goofy you'll beat it yeah
I don't play the game stop speculating
that's just actually playing I think
there was another way that I didn't
explore down but looks like this is the
place to go
oh all right how do I get this to work
well pebble Eva
I'd say Paul Paul believer oh I need
objects as I can't pull the lever down
objects do I need low pressure
Oh put on his podium oh okay
so we've seen the Teddy we've seen the
music I just haven't been picking them
up we see this banner we know where the
book is
wow thanks oh Jesus what the hell are
you doing
spin it Wales is a federal indie horror
game freaky to friction friction I'll
put this here
I don't know it's so crazy
don't turn around
[Music]
yeah I'm still bridging out about this
big brittle thing
stupid okay guessing I can carry
multiple things
I don't think up on this way yet
hey I said point I don't care what your
he's planted from his compass the
animation should I finish not time if
you want and they don't see why we need
this receipt if joining me has all those
funny little pedestals the breakroom
help you God Justin take the door I want
my room check that this one is what more
- I'm attitude okay so yeah the
company's pretty much don't bust and
it's falling down I can already see that
oh look it opens a door that actually
opens did we need something still
character doesn't eat everyone do we
need something from here why why open if
I don't need a hey like a little cinema
room slow okay so something around here
music stops
[Music]
tomatoes that were needed
[Applause]
[Music]
so we need
[Music]
nice tomato then I think and I collect
me when we going to get something
musical Donna got a lil will set it at
it okay what older paint at my old desk
come over the store unless I can open
this door man
[Music]
okay but there's definitely something
musical that I needed
Cantus take the music thing with me okay
this way step away Hey
he's gone again
you could heat it right yeah okay oh so
it will disappear you get that just be
something music did you miss something
what so musical instrument somewhere
around that I ah
alright alright getcha so cog in the
machine room I'm going to cows so creepy
yes cog I can't take them out of machine
oh here we go okay that's all now I just
need to get the ink flowing somehow
should you switch around here somewhere
yeah then I can start up the main power
if you will and your wedding switches I
do really love the art style of this
game I'm really sorry that I can't play
on solo highest quality I've had two
pairs of things down just as still
flagging a little bit I mean it's still
a little bit bad but we missed you here
on this channel
okay so it's a message this message
no the my objective to restore ink
pressure I've got to find a switch or
something could it be
it wasn't pretty much this way smooth to
Sweden why is this bum i sat out like
that so this room is so weird like I
expect something to be in here so switch
in here hello there stop it do it
[Music]
I do love it
[Music]
bamboo then wall switches
traffic wife's email what the hell's
wrong what did I just miss
but I think I was looking into County
work know what to do oh oh oh it was
just that one button and now it's ready
are you looking back
because it's sucking out all the power
from the life
Wendy are you there Andy what I'm ready
to be thrown aside we supposed to help
him it's just like Oh what have you done
not gonna tryna
oh so connect on his chest and it
started me Inc right okay so
[Music]
what do we do now Bundy so get to work
are those English you wait well it's
been boarded up
that's a me little while like equity yay
exit exit Hey
[Music]
Jessica like given of 11 I think we just
support Wendy to life I think
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
going down into some creepy base wish me
luck
until I code was like a face is coming
out like yeah and just like a little bit
like it I can't know it
yeah 'we have an axe I can use it to
kill brandy maybe probably not it's
gotta be any other
[Music]
what the hell oh I went in the center of
the pentagram
[Music]
that's some creepy I actually didn't
expect this to freak me out as much as
it did but I'm pretty impressed by that
I'm going to play the second one I think
I want anyway because I actually really
enjoyed that but if you want me to play
the second one more importantly please
leave a like on this video I'm ready so
I can play high quality but I hope it
was still enjoy enjoying and enjoyable
to watch because yeah I know I did have
a [ __ ] job man but none of them says the
premise of this game it was very
interesting the art style is beautiful
which is a shame way I calculated in a
really high quality but the art style is
great anyway do let me know your
thoughts on this game in the comments
below also discussion and have a lovely
day or evening bye
[Music]
you